[Música]
hablar de c's es intimidante hablar en
un text después del presidente de la
república es otro nivel
acompáñenme por favor a tomar una
relación profunda imaginándonos que
estamos contemplando el mar en alguna
playa
y exhalamos
y otra más
ustedes sabían que ese segundo respiro
nació en el océano la mitad del oxígeno
que nos mantiene vivos es producto de la
fotosíntesis de esos bosques submarinos
grandes extensiones de plancton que son
estos microorganismos que absorben
energía solar para fijar el carbono de
la atmósfera
al igual que un árbol este plancton debe
ser fertilizado por nutrientes los
cuales absorben en grandes cantidades
del excremento de las ballenas mientras
esas migran por todo el planeta montadas
sobre esas carreteras y avenidas que son
las grandes corrientes del mar que
además están transportando el calor
entre los trópicos y los polos regulando
nos el clima global
por eso es corrientes viajan también las
larvas de los peces y esas que
determinan a dónde se asientan las
especies que son comercialmente
importantes y que generan 100 millones
de trabajos a nivel global en las
pesquerías mundiales la mayoría de esos
en países en desarrollo
esos peces además constituyen la fuente
primaria de sustento proteínico para la
mitad de la población del mundo y
generan un comercio global de 150.000
millones de dólares al año y que
continúa creciendo año con año
y así como nosotros nos relajamos ahora
pensando en el océano 250 millones de
personas en el mundo eso es el
equivalente de la población de in on
indonesia el cuarto país más poblado del
mundo 250 millones buscan anualmente las
costas para su recreación siendo el
turismo marino la subsección de la
economía turística que más rápido está
creciendo
pero la economía azul no es solo el
turismo y la pesca si tomamos en cuenta
todas las actividades y los servicios
que nos provee el océano la oecd calcula
que la economía del océano genera un
valor agregado bruto cerca del 5% del
pib global y que para el 2030 este
número se va a doblar
es tanto lo que recibimos del océano y
nunca le damos el reconocimiento hasta
se nos olvida que ahí fue donde nació la
vida en el planeta que hacemos entonces
nosotros a cambio para agradecerle
cada año vertimos 8 millones de
toneladas de plástico en el océano esto
equivale a descargar un camión de basura
a cada minuto en alguna parte del
planeta costa rica el responsable de 42
de esas toneladas cada día 42 toneladas
eso es lo que pesa una ballena jorobada
y la mayoría de esas toneladas provienen
de objetos como las bolsas las botellas
los vasos o las vajillas que han sido
utilizados sólo una vez pero duran 500
años
en desintegrarse así como esas olas que
veíamos van y vienen
inevitablemente todo lo que ponemos en
el océano se nos regresa a través de la
acción del sol y la acción del mar ese
plástico se va descomponiendo hasta
pulverizar se en forma microscópica que
estamos ingiriendo en cada bocado de
mariscos y de pescado
pero nuestra posición sobre el océano no
es sólo plástica las aguas residuales
urbanas en muchas partes del mundo
todavía no son apropiadamente tratadas
para eliminar los rastros de nuestras
acciones en tierra por ejemplo los
fertilizantes agrícolas que llevan
grandes contenidos de nitrógeno causan
algo que se llama la eutroficación otra
fijación es cuando se aflora
descontroladamente alguna de las de los
microorganismos o algas que nosotros
conocemos como mareas rojas esas mareas
rojas son en muchos casos tóxicas y hay
que vedar la pesca generando grandes
pérdidas socioeconómicas y
preocupaciones muy serias de salud
pública
otro químico que agregamos de forma
excesiva pero tal vez no intencionada es
el dióxido de carbono en su afán por
balancear el clima el océano ha
absorbido un tercio de todas las
emisiones de co2 que se han producido
desde la época preindustrial ese co2 una
vez diluido en el agua está haciendo que
se reduzca el ph lo cual hace el asa el
agua más ácida con volviéndola
esencialmente corrosiva para las conchas
de calcio de muchos de los organismos en
la base de la cadena alimenticia
y como si fuera poco no sólo usamos de
su capacidad de absorber nuestros
desechos
dañinos sino que también estamos
llevando las actividades extractivas
hasta el límite los estudios dicen que
90 por ciento de las especies
comercialmente importantes están en su
límite de ser sobreexplotadas o ya no
dan abasto así como la metafórica
gallina de los huevos de oro si no le
damos tiempo a esas poblaciones para que
se regeneren estamos esencialmente
matando la capacidad de que ese recurso
exista en el futuro
el mar generoso como es está peleando
todas estas batallas al mismo tiempo
simultáneamente de forma acumulativa
pero estás llegando al punto en que
simplemente ya no da más esta urgencia
ha empezado a despertar al mundo la
agenda 2030 de las naciones unidas-
lanzada en el año 2015 por primera vez
reconoce este tema y lo pone en el mapa
de las decisiones mundiales en sus
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible se
contempla 1 el número 14 que se encarga
específicamente de proteger y preservar
la vida bajo el agua
sin embargo en el año 2018 cuando se
consultó con 3500 líderes mundiales y se
les pidió que clasificaran en orden de
importancia los 17 objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible el del mar cayó
siempre de último
muy por debajo de otras prioridades como
generar empleo y como la educación
esta falta de desconexión demuestra que
todavía no hemos entendido no hemos
captado no hemos internalizado tanto que
hace el océano por nosotros así como el
clima y la biosfera el océano es esa
base sobre la cual se sustenta una
economía sostenible una sociedad justa y
un planeta saludable
como vamos a pretender erradicar la
pobreza si no tenemos trabajos generados
por el mar
como eliminaríamos del hambre sin el
sustento de las pesquerías y de qué
valdría lograr controlar la temperatura
atmosférica si hacemos que dos tercios
del planeta sea corrosivo
pero hoy no es un día para contar malas
noticias hoy no vengo aquí para escribir
un obituario del océano hoy estoy acá
para contarles sobre su maravillosa
resiliencia y cómo la podemos aprovechar
para revivir el corazón del planeta
se está levantando un tsunami de
esfuerzos e iniciativas y campañas que
abogan por la conservación más
responsable y la gestión marina
por ejemplo en nuestro país es cada vez
más frecuente que hablamos que costa
rica de más que 52 kilómetros 52 mil
kilómetros cuadrados tenemos días costa
ricas más allá afuera en el territorio
azul y así como nuestro mismo nombre lo
indica somos ricos en las costas y quién
sabe cuánto más en esas profundidades
que se esconden y esperan a ser
descubiertas
un grupo de científicos costarricenses
trabaja o ahorita mismo en el golfo
dulce de la mano de expertos mundiales
trabajando en pioneras técnicas para
reforestar los arrecifes coralinos que
es donde nace un cuarto de las especies
del mar y además costa rica- pionera
lanzando esta campaña por la
descarbonización está no solo
transformando y revolucionando su
economía sino aliviando esas emisiones
de carbono que saturan a nuestro océano
pero no caminamos solos en este
transcurso en la región latinoamericana
chile y méxico son los grandes líderes
en proteger áreas marinas protegidas
extensas áreas que son como una cuenta
de bancos de ahorros donde se generan
dividendos naturales que luego son
aprovechados afuera de sus límites
pero los países son dueños nada más de
las 200 millas náuticas fuera de sus
orillas que pasa más allá más afuera el
45% de la tierra es lo que se llama un
bien común el alta mar esas aguas
internacionales que pertenecen a todos
nosotros pero como no están bajo la
jurisdicción de nadie son desprotegidas
por todas las naciones hoy mismo en las
naciones unidas se está haciendo el
tratado se está negociando el tratado de
alta mar 196 países del mundo están
negociando nuevas reglas sobre cómo se
va a proteger y utilizar sosteniblemente
la biodiversidad que existe en los mares
internacionales bajo esta sombrilla del
tratado será posible generar también
áreas marinas protegidas en esos
territorios afuera de la jurisdicción
nacional y vamos a tener un marco legal
bajo el cual se exijan estudios de
impacto ambiental cuando alguna nación
que era extraer un recurso que pertenece
a todos nosotros
así como el acuerdo de parís envió una
señal de que el mundo estaba listo para
trabajar de forma unida y colectiva
hacia la protección del clima este nuevo
tratado tiene la esperanza de unificar
todos estos esfuerzos y demostrar que el
mundo está consciente del océano
pero todos estos retos las escalas las
dimensiones del océano son tan enormes
que hablarles de él por 10 minutos
siempre se queda corto y estos esfuerzos
de los cuales se ha hablado también de
momentos son insuficientes
lo que les puedo regalar hoy es una
palabra clave y les voy a dar el secreto
de cómo restaurar la salud del mar esta
palabra es sumar
esa palabra contiene toda la esperanza y
todas las soluciones que necesitamos
llegó la hora de sumar por el mar
es hora de sumar historias reflexiones
intencionales para que cada día estemos
conscientes de todo lo que lo sea no
significa para nosotros eso es hora de
sumar alfabetización para que tanto
nuestros ciudadanos como nuestros
representantes estén muy mejor educados
sobre todo lo que el océano hace por
nosotros
es hora de sumar esfuerzos desde los
individuales hasta los colectivos para
que bajo un paradigma holístico se le
devuelva la salud al océano
sumar es la palabra clave porque sumar
es un verbo que requiere acción sumar
implica un trabajo conjunto sumar
inspira optimismo sumar significa
apropiación en el momento que la
humanidad sienta visceralmente que el
mar es suyo que cada una de estas
moléculas de oxígeno que fluye por
nuestras venas y es ese bichito que nos
gusta disfrutar proviene de allá
ese día habremos internalizado que el
océano fue nuestro pasado el océano
facilita nuestro presente y además si lo
protegemos será ese corazón que late
fuerte regalándonos un futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]